michael king
on the mound tonight
you can see it's kind of been a mixed
bag for him
off the glove of king directed out
toward odor
and mirrorfield beats it out and quickly
boyd turns to the dugout and says check
that on replay
and that's what carlos mendoza will do
[Music]
the proverbial bang bang
that replay would lead you to believe
he's out and he is out
and that's lined to left field again and
that will
bounce up against the wall and salvador
perez digs for second anduhar makes a
good throw and did salvy get around the
tag
he did
puts a man in scoring position for ryan
o'hearn
get out deep right field on a pitch down
and in and ryan o'hare
it's a two-run
first inning home run
and the royals
for the first time in 17 games
score a run in the first
danny duffy who has missed the last 31
games due to left forearm flexor strain
and he got him with a change up down and
away beauty
a great change up to finish
duffy man their first two hitters you
can't draw it up much better so danny
duffy has walked the bases loaded
fastball got him and the yankees leave
the bases loaded great job by danny he
has struck out four
now we go to the top of the third inning
the o2 cut on and missed lopez strikes
out the 3-2 struck him out slider way
away
annie duffy comes off the injured list
and he delivers two scoreless innings
and now a breaking ball is pulled to
short lopez to second one merrifield to
first for a double play just what
zimmer ordered here's ryan o'hearn
as o'hare swings and misses at another
change
now it'll be the young right-hander
carlos hernandez
and that is 13 walks in 13 innings
frazier lines one to right field solaire
heading toward right center can't get
there it bangs off the right side of
hill wall stanton has scored and here
comes and duary scores
that is a two-run double for clint
frazier and the game is tied at two
we go to the top of the fifth inning
while the game is tied
that struck him out swing slide her away
that's the fifth strikeout for king
and he gets plunked by king
and that loads the bases for o'hern
new picture is chad green
[Applause]
high fly ball
left field and duhar
makes the play and green comes on and
does the job
it will still be carlos hernandez
breaking ball for a strike
judge
thought it was ball four so he goes back
to have a word with gabe morales
nikki lopez
is in time two down in the fifth inning
all right got back in there got the out
there we go
stay in the park and let's get some runs
for him tell the story later
hernandez gets the yankees in order in
the bottom of the fifth
now we go to the top of the sixth we are
tied at two
high fly ball
left field and duhar
one away
fly ball right field
frazier makes the play
strike three dozier down looking a
strong one two three inning for chad
green and chad green is on for a second
full inning
high five ball
judges there
and he retires taylor
1-2 to lopez
a ground ball to short and glabor
throws the first two eight
popped up
luke voight
makes the play and boy once again chad
greene very sharp he's faced seven he's
retired them all and here comes barlow
and a 2-2 tie in the bottom of the
seventh
down goes judge on three pitches
beautiful
way to go
just all sliders
so two walks one given up by stomat
that's lemay hewitt second and now
sanchez at first for stanton
did he go
no he did not
and the bases are loaded eighth walk for
the yankees and that'll bring up luke
boyd the pitch
swinging a miss he struck him out with a
curveball barlow
creating some drama but then getting the
job done stranding three now we go to
the top of the eighth inning all tied at
two
britain's pitch is swung on and belted
high in the air deep to left field
that's a way back and that's gone
home run carlos santana off of one of
the best relievers in the game and the
royals take a three to two lead
britain made a mistake up in the zone
and santana absolutely demolished it
for his 12th home run of the year rbi
number 41 and the royals are in front so
frazier is on so here is odor
swung on and driven to right center in
the gap that ball is going to be
a three-run line drive bullet home run
into the bullpen and right center
shut the door of door
he drills a three-run home run to give
the yankees a 5-3 lead
and here we go ninth inning bases loaded
a young man without a big league hit
against
one of the game's great closers
ball four
sebastian rivero picks up his first big
league rbi
against aroldis chapman on a four pitch
walk
and the royals tie the game at four in
the ninth inning
check swing roller towards third the
throw by le mayhew safe and a run scores
the royals take the lead at five to four
well o'hern with a smile on his face
he made a joke last night about his
speed burning down the line and we all
know that ryan does not have above
average speed but he was legging it out
and that slow roller is a sweet base hit
and the royals take a 5-4 lead
now it's hammer time holland got the
save last night
working around a hit
that one is drilled to left field high
enough
a huge home run for gary sanchez
oh that gary is scary
hey homers and we're all tied at five
you know john and we talk all that we've
talked all this time about gary and that
balance and we just saw it on the big
screen hardly moved at all totally
balanced and what a shot that got out of
here in a nanosecond
so the winning run is in scoring
position for the yanks
one two
driven to left field going back dyson
still back turning loki it's off the
road here comes wade
he scores and the yankees wins six to
five
they snatch a win out of the jaws of
defeat and come back with two runs in
the bottom of the ninth inning for an
unlikely 6-5 victory